hey guys welcome to another episode of
the Wednesday checkup today I want to
tell you about a really interesting
patient encounter I had just the other
day and then we're gonna follow up that
story with one of my favorite segments
mailtime you ready my nurse rooms the
patient takes all the vitals brings all
the information including the chief
complaint to me tells me that the
patient has normal vital signs normal
blood pressure pulse high 90s that he's
mid 60 year-old male that the breathing
rate is normal and that the patient's
chief complaint is that there's this
redness surrounding the right foot that
the the patient is worried about that
the antibiotics haven't really that they
haven't really seen an improvement in
the redness of the right foot despite
using antibiotics for the last 48 hours
prior to walking into the room with the
patient I did look at the electronic
health record and found that they have
an extensive list of medical conditions
and are taking a lot of medications for
them hypothyroid osteoporosis diabetes
type 2 high cholesterol atrial
fibrillation so I know that this patient
does have medications on board and other
conditions at play it's important for me
as a doctor to check that before going
into a room so that I can see how maybe
those illnesses and those medications
can be factoring into the current
problem after hearing the story about
the foot I asked the patient there are
any other complaints and I generally
have a list of what we call a review of
systems or ask a few general questions
just to see how the patient's doing
overall constitutional symptoms like
fever fatigue unexplained weight loss
then we have the cardiovascular ones
palpitations chest pain then with
respiratory ones shortness of breath you
sort of get the idea the patient did
mention that he felt a little bit more
short of breath than usual he attributed
that to the pain and discomfort from his
right leg that he thought maybe he
wasn't sleeping as well there all these
sorts of explanations he had in his mind
for why that was happening so I listened
to the patient's lungs crystal clear no
problem when I listened to the patient's
heart I hear something that I didn't
expect to hear the patient was having an
irregularly irregular rhythm meaning
that it was an irregular rate that it
was above 100
and it was an irregular rhythm meaning
that it didn't have a consistent beat to
it but boom boom boom boom that is
essentially the beat that we would hear
if a patient has atrial fibrillation now
I know this patient has a history of
that so it makes a little bit more easy
for me to expect to hear that but a
patient who has atrial fibrillation
actively at a fast rate is dangerous
reason being is the heart doesn't like
to be beating very rapidly for a long
period of time at rest your heart rate
should be somewhere between sixty and a
hundred however my patient was beating
somewhere in the low 100's when I
listened and I checked their pulse
I asked the patient have you felt any
palpitations in the last few days
meaning that they feel like their
heart's racing or beating outside of
their chest that's a very common way to
explain it and the patient says to me
you know doctor the last few days I did
feel a little bit and I wasn't sure if
it's my a fib the atrial fibrillation
kicking in but it went away so I assumed
nothing of it said okay let me do
something let me get an EKG just to see
how your heart is doing how fast is it
beating confirm that this is in fact a
fib and we'll move on from there and we
sort of put the foot issue to the side
because a he's actively being treated
for it and be the more concerning issue
for the time being would be the heart
upon getting the EKG we found out that
my physical exam was correct and the
patient was having afib and he was
having afib with RvR I know that's a
mouthful afib is that atrial
fibrillation where the top of the heart
beats irregularly at an irregular rate
but then his ventricles as a result of
having those excess beats was also
beating very quickly that's a lower
portion of the heart that actually pumps
out the blood to the rest of the body
his heart was working very hard to in
order to maintain this rhythm but this
isn't normal my patients at rest his
heart shouldn't be beating that quickly
upon further review of that EKG I found
that he was having segments of what's
known as st depressions and what st
depressions specifically on an EKG
signify is that the heart isn't getting
enough blood and it's suffering it's
essentially being choked out we call
this a type 2 mi which is a type 2 heart
attack when the heart is beating so fast
that
it's not getting enough blood because
it's being overworked and there's actual
damage to the muscle tissue of the heart
so I told them that we have to call 911
we have to get him sent over to the
hospital in order to contain this rate
slowed the rate down and then figure out
what our long-term plan is gonna be now
this was very stressful because the
patient started getting emotional they
started getting worried and upset
because they thought they were coming in
for their foot but here we are
diagnosing with a heart attack my
patient ended up going to the emergency
room they gave him IV medications they
made sure that the rate subsided that
the enzymes that were leaking from the
damaged heart started going down and the
heart was improving and once that
started happening
they had a cardiovascular doctor see the
patient and decide what the plan was
going to be moving forward and part of
that was to increase the dosage of one
medication and decrease the dosage of
another and then have them follow up in
one week with that same cardiologist the
point of this being is that as a doctor
you never know what to expect especially
at a family medicine office I had a
patient on my schedule for an infected
foot and Here I am diagnosing with a
heart attack that they were walking
around with they actually walked a few
blocks to my office a mistake I see a
lot of young doctors make is to get
pigeonholed into a diagnosis they see a
red swollen foot on their screen they
only look at that body part and they say
okay well here's a diagnosis for this
and they forget that there's a whole
person sitting in front of them it's
important to take that whole person to
consideration when treating a patient
yes the the complaint is about an
infected foot but the real concern was
with my patients heart and the only way
I could find that out is through a
thorough history and physical exam had I
not done those things just look at the
foot said okay the foots improving you
know keep taking her inside my legs
let's have you follow-up I would have
been doing a huge disservice to my
patient we have to treat the human
sitting in front of us and not the
ailment we're not the complaint that
they're bringing to us the more you can
do that as a doctor as a person as a
police officer really doesn't even
matter the better you're going to fare
and the better the person sitting in
front of you is gonna fare let's have
some fun and open some packages be a
male type
courtesy of my mailbag West Orange New
Jersey that's not too far okay oh these
are gonna be cufflinks cuz I could tell
from the cuff link box oh these are dull
these are little stethoscopes oh look at
this little checkerboard tie if it
matches you got to wear it
whoa easy work thank you for your
wonderful gift I think I look pretty fly
and I can't wait to wear these cufflinks
Fort Walton Beach Florida oh did you get
bear his favorite toy no joke
this is bears favorite toy little
squirrels that you put in here then he
has to get them out bear I have a gift
for you oh they make noise
this is legit bears favorite toy he's
gonna lose his mind well that's a mug Oh
me and rocks he's sitting side by side
how did you do this husky dad me and
Roxy hanging out thank you family okay
this one's from Texas whoa whoa
Swarovski pens with my name on them but
the only thing is I'm not a do and MD
I'm just the deal problematic this is
from Hungary and I've been to Hungary
many at times not many a times I've been
there twice I imagine this is gonna be a
drawing cuz it's with some really heavy
cardboard there let's see dear Mike I
couldn't decide so I did both hope you
liked it best regards me what this is by
far the best drawing I've ever seen you
give me in my life this is pencil folks
is this ridiculous or what do these are
amazing I'm gonna have these frames I
don't know where I'm gonna put them coz
it's kind of awkward hanging pictures of
yourself in your own house but these are
amazing like this looks like me beuh
Smith or be a Smith please send me your
Instagram I want to put this on my story
and share this with the world your heart
is amazing I mean like you can't draw
better than that this is from Ohio okay
okay here we go we got sucks get out of
here
sucks with Roxie and bears face on them
come on now come on I'm gonna wear these
to work
and people get a judge mean I don't even
care at all Thank You Kenyatta very much
appreciated stay being an awesome nurse
I send you a t-shirt I make a tower
small family farm I guess you were a
large or extra-large so whichever one
doesn't fit feel free to do whatever you
want with it okay this is a very
interesting shirt support your local
beekeeper I'm down with that but why is
the be throwing up fun fact all my
videos are now captioned in English and
Spanish so click here to check this one
out and have a good laugh as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]